foreign
good morning everyone apologies for the
slight delay in getting our meeting
started here this morning but
as you may have seen there's a lot of
paper flying around we have a lot of
amendments to bills that we're going to
be
exacting here this morning
and as you probably also noticed there's
a lot of activity Happening Here on the
State House complex this morning with
bills being heard in other committees
and rallies being staged to support or
oppose those bills and other committees
so it's a it's a busy morning
but let's start our day the way we
customarily do by standing and joining
representative Doug Thomas as he leads
us in the pledge
foreign
okay so our job here this morning is to
pass judgment on 12 bills we received
from the Senate we've had public
hearings on all 12 bills
and we have amendments to propose on
several of these bills
now
the bills have been listed in numerical
order but we may not take them up in
that order because
there are additional amendments that
still may be in the pipeline
so we may have to take things up out of
order
in order to allow the pipeline to
deliver its its contents
and to prove my point there we're going
to take up
Senate Bill 225 first
so I'm going to open an exact session on
Senate Bill 225
and I recognize
representative Troy murner for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move on to pass
on Senate Bill 225. chair recognizes
representative naughter
I second the motion chair recognizes
representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman uh I
propose amendment uh
2023-1397h which corrects A Minor error
in at the beginning of the bill
so it's been moved and seconded that we
resolve to judge House Bill 225 as
worthy of ought to pass subject to an
amendment
and so the question now is on the
amendment at
2023-1397h which essentially just
corrects a mistake made by OLS
and we know that os does a fantastic job
in very seldom makes mistakes but
they are human and we all make mistakes
right so is there any discussion on this
amendment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk if he's
ready
wait a minute wait a minute okay
we're about to call the roll
on the amendment
to
Senate Bill 225
this is we are doing government work so
it does require a form as you all are
well aware
okay so the clerk is now ready to call
the roll on amendment
1397h to Senate bill 225.
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington yes
Troy Marner yes John lewicki yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom closure
yes James Summers yes Kat McGee
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas
yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
20-0
yes oh chair excuse me
okay by a vote of 20 to nothing the
amendment
1397 H is adopted
and we'll now have to call the roll on
the question of ought to pass as amended
is there any further discussion
see uh Wendy Thomas representative
Thomas yes thank you um
I was thinking about this bill last
night um because apparently I don't have
a life
um and remember the question I asked
about the date it's the committee ending
on November 1st and the report being due
on November 1st the reason that that was
a an issue for me and I'm not trying to
be a pain in the butt even though my dad
says that's my middle name but if you
issue the report and you've got
questions on this complex report who do
you ask your questions of if the
committee has been dissolved
thank you
good question I think that even if the
committee is dissolved the members of
the committee who have signed the report
would be available to answer answer
questions
no different than any other report that
we well I mean it's not enough for me to
vote against this but it's just I mean
your explanation yesterday was that this
is the way it's always done perhaps we
should re-look at the way it's always
been done
I'm just okay good suggestion by the way
we can't really move on without a motion
and a second so I'm going to recognize
representative merner to make a motion
I make a motion that we ought to pass
Senate Bill 225 as amended
representative notter a second the
motion so it's moved and seconded now
that we resolve to judge this bill otpa
now further discussion
I'm done I said okay representative uh
representative murder
yes I was a part of the
commission and the reason first of all
we had a commission set of a committee
the bill was in the second year of the
session so we we went with the
commission and we thought we could get
this thing done by last November and as
you see in the report we had a ton of
material we met quite oftenly over at
dra all summer and into the fall and we
knew that we we got a lot of things I
end up but we still have a little bit
more to go as uh was in test of
testifying yesterday so uh it's going to
be the same play as all back at the
table and we're going to try to get this
thing I complete can I uh your
recognized representative Wendy Thomas
um I completely understand that I mean
which is why you know I'm going to vote
for this bill to go forward
however we've all recognized that this
is going to be a very complex report
and I'm I'm assuming it will generate
questions
this is a very complex thing when it
came to the tax and and I don't think
there's only a couple of members here
when we back we did 700 and in the month
of October we kept track back when we
had a retained bill on this which we
deleted this section of that and I think
Mike can testified as we had 13 hours of
work on a work study that fall just
trying to iron out things in this we
still didn't get anywhere in them when
we had to put a committee together and
through Ways and Means and they ended up
getting this bill done and it took
another I forget like close to a year to
get it all ironed out so this is the
last piece of what we're trying to get
done
okay yeah no I appreciate it I think
we're in a basic agreement here so
I'll ask the clerk now to call the role
on the question of ought to pass as
amended on Senate bill 225.
Doug Thomas yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy Marner yes
John lewicki yes Lex brajney yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom blochet yes James
Summers yes Kat McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie creation
yes lucious partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose yes 20-0 by a vote of
twenty to zero
the committee resolves to report out
Senate Bill 225 as ought to pass as
amended and without objection we'll go
on the consent calendar
no objections recorded So
SB 225 goes on consent
I'll close the exact session on SB 225
and now we can open an exec session on
Senate bill 16.
and
I will move the motion of ought to pass
on Senate Bill 16 and recognize
representative Thomas
second
it's moved and seconded that we pass a
judge Senate Bill 16 to be worthy of
ought to pass and I also move amendment
number
2023-1408 h
and recognize representative Thomas
yeah second to adopt
so it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt Amendment
1408 H so let me explain this amendment
basically what this amendment does is it
adds a Sunset date to the
uh legislation proposed in Senate Bill
and at the
suggestion of
representative McWilliams we made this a
six-year
Sunset period
and so
the repeal takes effect on July 1st of
2029 which will be roughly six years
from the date of its
Passage
so that's what the amendment does
discussion on the amendment
seeing representative Wendy Thomas no um
just that I appreciate that it's the at
the end of a term which is what
representative McWilliams had suggested
so thank you
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of adoption of
amendment number 1408 h
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy merner yes
John lewicki yes
Lex brajny yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes James
Summers yes Kat McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Carmen yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes 20-0
by a vote of 20 to zero Amendment
1408 H is adopted I now move ought to
pass as amended and recognize
representative Thomas second
it's moved and seconded that we resolved
to
judge house bill Senate Bill 16
as amended by
Amendment 1408 H to be worthy of ought
to pass as amended is there any further
discussion
seeing none
as soon as he's ready I'll ask the clerk
to call the roll on the question of
ought to pass as amended
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine otter yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy Marner yes John lewicki yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet
yes James Summers yes Kam McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie creation
yes Lucia's partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris Munns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman yes 20-0.
by a vote of 20 to zero the committee
resolves to
report out on Senate Bill 16 as
worthy of ought to pass without
objection we'll put this on the consent
calendar
did I say out to pass I meant ought to
pass as amended and seeing no objection
we'll put this on the consent calendar
and I will write the committee report by
the way representative merner will write
the committee report for Senate bill
225.
and so with that we'll close that
executive session and move on next
to opening an executive session for
Senate bill 40.
and the chair recognizes representative
Thomas
uh motion to
OTP send Bill 40. chair recognizes
representative Bernardi
second the motion it's moved and
seconded that we judge Senate Bill 40 to
be worthy of ought to pass I will move
Amendment
2023-1373h and recognize representative
Bernardi second the motion it's moved
and seconded that we adopt
Amendment
1373h and I will now speak to the
amendment
this amendment was generated in direct
response to comments made during the
public hearing that
this bill could potentially set a
precedent for redefining customer
generator to be
something different than what it already
has been defined in statute as being
so the language on lines 17 through 21
was added to the
Amendment
to specify that a hydroelectric
generator that is not the utility
customer account of record at the point
of interconnection to the electric grid
was at one time owned by the current
electric utility customer or a prior
electric
utility customer at the point of
interconnection to the electric grid and
that such an electro hydroelectric
generator that is not the electric
utility customer account of record
submits its initial proposed process and
methodology described below to the
Department of energy
basically what this amendment does is it
restricts
this entire bill
to two
companies Monadnock paper
and Brookfield Hydro
and the reason that we decided that this
was worthy of doing even though it kind
of focuses on two individual com
companies rather than a broad policy for
that applies to everybody is because
both of these companies
when their Hydro facilities were
interconnected to the grid they were
wired in a non what we would consider
today to be a non-standard manner
and it's too expensive to undo what was
done when they were initially wired so
what this bill does it is it essentially
grants an exception to those two
companies it would be very similar to a
zoning Board of adjustment granting a
variance or an exception to a zoning
ordinance
uh that is a good analogy for what this
bill does from an ad knock paper and
Brookfield Hydro
so that's what the amendment does are is
there any need for discussion
representative Wendy Thomas
um just curious do you know who did the
wiring was it um a utility or was it a
private company that did it
well it was an Internet interconnection
to the grid so I anticipate that the
utility did it
but I don't know that for certain I'm
not sure anybody knows that does anybody
in the audience have any direct
knowledge of the answer to that question
I didn't think so uh if you really want
to know we could research that but thank
you I'm just curious
okay thank you further discussion on the
amendment
seeing none I guess we can proceed to a
vote so I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll on the question of adoption of the
amendment 1373 h
hang on what did I do out of order
foreign
motions in seconds
we already did them okay we're good all
right
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy murner yes
John lewicki yes Lex brajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom plushie yes
James Summers yes Kat McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial
point of order we are talking about the
amendment the amendment yes 1373 H yes
yes
uh Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Rose
yes 20-0
on the amendment so by a vote of 20 to
zero the amendment is adopted that's
Amendment 1373h
and I'll now recognize representative
Thomas for a motion on the bill motion
to a otpa Senate Bill 40. recognize
chairman as representative Bernardi
second the motion moved and seconded
that we judge Senate Bill 40 to be
worthy of ought to pass as amended
further discussion
seeing none as soon as the clerk is
ready I'll ask him to call the roll on
the question about to pass as amended by
Amendment 1373 h on Senate bill 40.
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington
yes Troy murner yes John lewicki yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom plouge
yes James Summers yes Kat McGee
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes Lucius partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose yes 20-0 by a vote of 20
to nothing the committee resolves to
report out Senate Bill 40 as worthy of
ought to pass as amended
vote was 20 to nothing
shall we put this on the consent
calendar or is it too complex a bill for
that
concerns
representative Harrington I think the
fact that it is so complex and it took
us this long to work it out there's
nobody in this room that wants to try to
explain this on the floor of the house
put it on the consent calendar please
good point good point okay on consent it
goes
happily so I like the way this is going
so far this morning
all right uh so
representative Thomas will write the
committee report for Senate bill 40. and
with that we'll close the exact session
on Senate Bill 40. Mr chair
representative Wendy Thomas
um when you say representative Thomas
could you just please identify which
representative Thomas
sorry that's okay representative we know
that representative Doug Thomas made the
motion so I know but if people are
listening that's the only thing I never
call her one you are what the taller one
I'm the taller one
all right so the taller representative
Thomas will write the committee report
for Senate bill 40.
all right
since we're on a roll here let's move on
to Senate bill 113. I will open a
a executive session on Senate Bill 113
and I will move
ought to pass on Senate bill
113 and representative recognized
representative McGee for a motion for a
second
yes I second it it's moved and seconded
that we judge Senate Bill 113 to be
ought to pass as amended and I now move
amendment number one three nine nine
Dash H and recognize representative
McGee
thank you
okay I'll recognize representative
Thomas then second did you say McGee I
did oh I didn't hear you I'm sorry yeah
I I'll make a motion to adopt Amendment
okay she seconds yeah representative
McGee seconds the motion
all right sorry I didn't say that
clearly clearly enough so that you could
hear
all right it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt a motion number
1399h and since I propose that motion I
will explain it the amendment so what
this amendment does is you'll recall
when we passed HB 549 last year
we put two guard rails in place
to check the growth of the system
benefits charge the first one was the 65
percent uh
electricity
Energy Efficiency improvements
and the other one was the
Consumer Price Index
inflation Adder for the system benefits
charge and to that we added a 0.25
percent
sweetener
well since Senate Bill 113
restricts the 65 percent limit to yearly
or annually instead of Lifetime
we felt it would be prudent to tighten
up the other guard rail by removing the
0.25 percent Adder so that's what this
bill does or this amendment does if you
look at line 19
it strikes the language plus 0.25
percent all as calculated and
adds the language as determined and
verified by the department of
and of course the rest of that sentence
is by the department of energy so that's
all the bill does is it deletes that
adder and uh
this allows us to pass a bill that gives
both sides something that they feel is
appropriate and so I urge you to support
this amendment and I would like to hear
if there's any discussion
representative McGee yeah I just would
like to reiterate what I said in
yesterday's hearing I I
just want to make it clear that the
interpretation of the language as being
lifetime isn't something that we you
know lost anything on because it was
really a misreading of what was intended
by the 65 percent rule which had never
been extrapolated to include lifetime
before so I don't feel like it's a quid
pro quo but I do think that the adder is
not significant enough for us to
quibble over
thank you further discretion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of adoption of
the amendment 2023-1399h
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy Marner yes John lewicki yes Lex
barajny yes Katie Bernardi yes Tom
plazier yes James Summers yes Kam McGee
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes
Ned Reynolds yes
Cameron Bose yes 20-0.
by a vote of 22-0
Amendment 2023 19 1399 H is adopted I
will now move
ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill
113 and recognize representative McGee
yes I'd like to second that
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge Senate Bill 113 worthy of ought to
pass by Amendment 1399 H as amended by
1399 H is there any further discussion
seeing none as soon as the clerk is
ready I will ask him to call the roll on
the question about to pass is amended by
1399 h
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy Marner yes John lewcki yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom closure
yes James Summers yes Kat McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes
20-0
so by a vote of 20 to 0 Senate Bill 113
as amended by Amendment 1399 h
will be reported out as ought to pass as
amended and without objection we'll put
it on the consent calendar
seeing no objection on the consent
calendar it goes I will write the
committee report for Senate bill
113.
and with that we'll close the exact
session on Senate bill 113.
and since we are on a roll here
a representative not her there's an FN
on the bill so can it go on I don't
think it can go on consent calendar okay
why why can't it
if the
FN says that it's indeterminate
that the department can't calculate what
the cost can be then it can go on the
consent calendar for all practical
purposes the FN doesn't exist
okay
all right
let's keep this train moving and move on
to
opening an exec session on Senate bill
161.
and on this bill I'd like to recognize
representative merner for a motion
yes thank you Mr chairman I move
ought to pass on Senate Bill 161. chair
recognizes representative Kaplan
yeah I'll second that it's moved and
seconded that we
adopt Senate bill
161 and we have an amendment
so I will move Amendment 2023-1346h
on Senate Bill 161 and recognize
representative merner
I'll second the amendment it's moved and
seconded that we adopt Amendment
1346 H now we discussed this amendment
yesterday at our work session
this amendment was requested by the
department of energy
makes a couple of small changes on rule
on lines 6 and 15.
indicating that the department has the
authority and the ability to create
rules or orders in order to implement
the rest of the bill
and there is a
correction in lines 26 and lines 16 on
page 2 where the word defined was
changed to the word described
and those are the changes that this
amendment makes is there any discussion
on the amendment
well seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll on the question of the
amendment 1346 H and its adoption
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy merner yes
John lewicki yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom plushie yes
James Summers yes Camp McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie creation
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose yes 20-0 by a vote of 20
to zero the amendment's 1346 H is
adopted by the committee
and I'll now recognize representative
merner for a motion
thank you I move Senate Bill 161
ought to pass as amended
recognize representative Kaplan
yeah I'll second that
moved and seconded that we judge
Senate Bill 161 to be worthy of ought to
pass as amended by
1346h further discussion
representative Harrington
yeah I'll make this quick because I made
this point yesterday I think uh having
subsidized solar for someone making 80
of the area meaning income it's just way
too high uh someone could be making less
than that living in an apartment where
it's not even possible to put up solar
or maybe a mobile home or a small house
where they don't have the land for it
and they're going to be subsidizing the
electric bill of someone who could very
possibly be making more money than they
can so I can't vote for this bill
further discretion representative Kaplan
yeah we had a lot of discussion about
carve outs under the net metering
provisions and this is another one but I
think it's our responsibility to do
everything we can especially for
low-income people who are suffering uh
High rates and so
this is the least we can do is a little
bit at a time and everything helps
and so we owe it to our constituents to
get this passed
thank you further discussion
representative muns thank you Mr chair I
I would just point out that um 80
percent of the average Mark our average
median income in the state in most areas
it's about it's between 52 and 55 000
The Only Exception is the Seacoast and
Nashua where it's uh in the sixty
thousand dollar range so I don't think
we're talking about people that are
making exorbitant amounts of money
further discussion representative McGee
I think that the last thing I draw our
attention to is that this is actually
follow through on SB 270 for low-income
uh solar from last session and so it's
sort of the follow-on Bill of how to
implement that for the doe and this
portion you know specifically calls out
public housing authorities
um or how or housing project that's as
described in so I think we are uh we do
have guard rails around this in terms of
what populace is being served and it's
just
um you know it's just giving the rest of
the language around it what percentage
of the people in that group uh would
fall into the income categories that
would allow them to qualify so I I don't
see any problem with the language in
terms of anybody getting an undue
advantage
thank you representative lewicki
thank you Mr chairman I just Echo what
my representative McGee just said
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask clerk to call the
roll on the question of ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 161 as amended by
1346h
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington no
Troy merner yes
John lewicki yes Lex barajny no
JD Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers
yes
Kat McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes delicious partial
yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Carmen yes Ned
Reynolds yes
chairman of Oz yes
18-2
so by a vote of 18 to two the committee
will pour it out we'll report out
Senate Bill 161 as ought to pass as
amended
and uh it will not go on the consent
calendar I suspect it'll go on the
regular calendar
and representative merner will write the
committee report will there be a
Minority Report
representative Harrington will write a
minority let me finish please
um I don't think there's any point in
not putting this on the consent calendar
so
save everybody some time
all right so representative uh
Harrington thinks we ought to put this
on consent calendar any objection to
that
the other one would be Lex
okay I guess it does go on the consent
calendar after all
so that's five in a row on the consent
calendar that's pretty awesome
all right so we will close the exact
session then on Senate bill 161.
I think our path is probably going to
get a little rockier from this point
forward but we'll continue on as we've
had a pretty good run so far
so
let's move next to
Senate Bill 166 relative to grid
modernization
well maybe not
I haven't seen the amendment come
through on this one yet
my Amendment or your Amendment Mr
chairman
was that was that an amendment we
discussed yesterday yes and you said
that you thought it was reasonable
and that you supported it
it's 13.
all right so it's 1392.
what was the number again please 1392
1392.
yeah
so it's here somewhere
Mr chairman I can I can
um give a synopsis if you like
it was well we're all looking for our
copy of 1392
I just found my copy of 1391 which is
for 167.
while we're discussing that uh please
representative McGee oh here it is 1392.
please representative McGee
when you and I we didn't make a motion
yet so yes when you and I spoke over the
weekend
um there was a pending amendment that
you had put in with some minor
um minor changes correct and I took your
changes and I um reviewed the language
that had been submitted to us around how
um
how pricing would be considered
um and so I added language that I
thought would make things more clear
um on basically how how credits would be
extended on exports to the distribution
grid to reduce retail load so I read
that right uh to the committee yesterday
and that was what you said you supported
correct yeah so I found it and so I'm
going to make a motion for Senate Bill
ought to pass and I'll recognize
representative McGee for
a second
I'll second it and now I'll recognize
representative McGee for emotion on an
amendment
turn my mic off
um I'd like to make a motion to accept
Amendment 2023-1392h
okay so this amendment was distributed
to members of the committee yesterday
yep
it's amendment number
2023-1392h I second the motion by
representative McGee to adopt this
amendment
you said
1392 H is the amendment number
so what this amendment does to
repeat what some of what representative
McGee just said is it strikes the word a
pilot
on line five and
inserts one to five Pilots
in in replacement of that stricken
phrase
it then changes the word may to shall
on line eight
and it adds a new sentence on lines 9
through 12.
that says that the Public Utilities
Commission May approve utility
participation in a pilot for transactive
energy and distributed energy resources
and the associated Advanced metering
infrastructure
as components of grid modernization if
the jurisdictional conflicts under
paragraph 3 are successfully resolved
and then further down
it aligns
21 through 27 it strikes
language that was there previously and
replaces it with explanatory language
that says that that describes how credit
for transmission
shall be allocated transmission costs
shall be allocated to the distribution
utility Network customer
and this is all language that Chris Bilo
Clifton Beeler rather discussed with us
during the public hearing and I spoke
with Chris Cliff offline about it I
understand it thoroughly and I agree
that this is decent language to add to
this legislation
does anybody else have any discussion on
this amendment
representative Thomas has a question
with all the confusion of finding this
amendment did we actually complete our
motion to adopt OTP
yes I I moved OTP McGee seconded it okay
and then McGee moved the amendment and I
seconded that
representative Harrington
just a quick comment this is a good idea
but don't underestimate how much time
and work it's going to take don't expect
something to come back out of the puc in
six months on this trying to find out
the exact credit for transmission on
distribution just with generation it's
going to be a very technical and
time-consuming effort so just like I say
it's a good idea but don't hold your
breath
I believe the POC has a docket open on
this question already so
the investigation has already started
any further discussion on the amendment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of adoption of
the amendment 1392 h
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington
yes
Troy murner yes John lewcki yes Lex
brajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom poche yes
James Summers yes Kat McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes
Lucius partial yes Tony Kaplan yes Chris
muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes
20-0
okay by a vote of 20 to nothing
Amendment
1392 H is adopted
and so now we'll move on and I will make
a motion
of ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill 166 and recognize representative
McGee
yeah select a second that motion
did you second it
yes okay representative McGee seconds
the motion of ought to pass as amended
by 1392 H is there any further
discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of ought to
pass is amended on Senate bill 166.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine naughter yes Michael Harrington
yes Troy Marner yes John lewcki yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom blogee
yes James Summers yes McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Carmen
yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes
20-0
by a vote of twenty to zero
Senate Bill
166 as amended by
1392 h
is adopted by the committee
and
without objection we'll put it on the
consent calendar
seeing no objections or hearing none
this bill will go on consent along with
the other
five we've already put there
and I will ask representative McGee if
she'd be willing to write the committee
report on this bill happy too
sorry did you say yes I said happy too
yes I'll do it thank you
all right so with that we'll close the
exec session on Senate bill 166.
so since we're right here why don't we
continue with Senate bill 167.
so I'll open a public hearing on Senate
bill 167.
and recognize representative Thomas
Doug Thomas
sorry representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chairman on
sb167 I motion the itl
Fair recognizes representative Bernardi
it's moved and seconded that we itl
Senate Bill 167 relative to Green
hydrogen and energy and infrastructure
and the chair recognizes representative
Thomas
thank you Mr chairman
um we have no objection whatsoever to uh
green hydrogen but the bill contains
Provisions in there that speak of a tax
or subsidy to rate payers and that is
one area that we we don't agree on but
the hydrogen is a good idea we like the
idea but the taxes part of it is
something that we just agree with
further discussion representative Kaplan
yeah we heard in uh testimony from
Senator Waters uh when he came to
present on this bill that in order to
really attract
the the federal money that's available
for green hydrogen we need to show that
we have some skin in the game so to
speak and that is why those tax credits
exist
so I think if we're serious
about becoming part of a
clean energy system in the region and
not being the whole of the donut when it
comes to receiving this money and we've
seen that there's a lot of movement
around green hydrogen and creating a hub
we need to step up our game so to speak
and and so that's it's a it's a pretty
well-known fact that you know uh
State participants need to show that
they are taking this seriously and so
that's why this credit these credits
exist
thank you further discussion on this
representative lewicki thank you Mr
chairman
um at this time we are talking about
something that's purely hypothetical in
New Hampshire there is no hydrogen there
is no one to use it
and whether we should become the venture
capitalist of Last Resort in my mind the
answer is no this is if there are people
in industry or wherever who want to
start a hydrogen economy then let's see
them do this uh initiate it rather than
us
I would make the observation that when
government tries to help or regulate
technology it's always too little too
late
and this bill I think is a classic
example of that
it's trying to
pave the way for something that is very
little well not well understood at this
point in time and if it's just a Chase
for money that's not the purpose of the
science technology and energy committee
we passed judgment on
policy that relates to
science and technology and energy not on
chasing
subsidies chasing federal grants
establishing taxpayer subsidies none of
that is part of what we should be doing
here so I can't support this bill for
that reason
representative Harrington has a comment
just a quick follow-up to that we do
have a department of energy now and one
of the functions is to go after Federal
money for projects that with this we
don't need specific legislation to do it
we have a department that's well
equipped to take care of that
representative partial
just like you chair I
um would possibly take a point in that
our job is also to deliver uh cost
savings to the people of New Hampshire
and so our job to some degree is chasing
dollars however in this particular case
I will vote with the itl legislation
over environmental concerns about
interaction of hydrogen not being a
greenhouse gas and of itself
but it does tend to affect free radicals
in our upper atmosphere and it tends to
uh uh what you should be doing their job
of basically uh working on the methane
and since uh 2020 was a record year for
methane I'm very concerned about pumping
anything in creating do any further
damage to our atmosphere
further discussion representative Kaplan
yeah thank you Mr chair um
as far as the the free radical question
uh it's you know from from what I've
read that would only really become a
problem if hydrogen
became
much larger part of our generation mix
and and our Energy System in general so
what this is talking about is what green
hydrogen is intended to do is provide
the last mile so to speak of
decarbonization and very hard to reach
Industries such as cement and steel
making Transportation where uh the
current elect Electric System really
even with a much larger scale of
renewable input would not really be able
to take
to take effect so green hydrogen is seen
as an essential part of our move to
decarbonize and become a net zero
economy
and it's a shame that New Hampshire
continues to drag its heels in that
transition and I think it's as
represented partial sites to the
detriment of our constituents and the
cost savings that could benefit
everybody
representative murder has a comment yes
it was in the papers we have a big
hydrogen plant under construction now up
in the north country and I brought him
here five years ago was a running koa's
Economic Development Corporation and the
reason they picked out of state they
were from Utah
is because we have we're business
friendly here and they search the area
to find a site so I disagree with you
comments respectively Mr Kaplan but uh
we already have advantages here and they
will come here thank you representative
McGee
thank you Mr chair
um I I actually view the bill a little
bit differently I think you know what I
heard from Senator Waters in introducing
it was that this is an enabling bill
that is looking at potential future
infrastructure that we don't want to be
ignoring so it kind of sets up in
statute
consideration for how we would approach
it if we were to welcome this type of
industry and to really anticipate that
it's coming I think when we say we're
that's not our job I mean if it's not
our job who's we're saying the
department of energy they can't
necessarily go after the money unless
we've already passed laws in the state
that show the federal government that we
actually are you know preparing
ourselves so I look at it as an
infrastructure bill and I am agnostic in
terms of I'm not an expert on hydrogen
or green hydrogen or gray hydrogen and I
only know what I've read but I do know
that
um that the fuel mix is changing in the
region and I don't want to see New
Hampshire be behind the eight ball on
infrastructure so I'll be voting on to
pass
further discussion
representative munz thank you Mr chair I
would just Echo the comments of
Representative McGee that you know this
isn't enabling piece of legislation
we're not mandating anything
um the legislature for years has
utilized a few fiscal levers that it has
such as the business and profits tax to
encourage
policies that the legislature believes
is in the best interest of the State of
New Hampshire and I would also add that
this is another this is a um this would
be a you know a jobs Bill a a a way to
create
good paying jobs
that could attract people to New
Hampshire to help us
address some of the demographic
challenges that we have and the
resulting fiscal challenges so I will be
also voting ought to pass representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman uh when I look at
this I think of exactly what we've had
before with the electric car debate we
talked about in here in actually an
executive committee discussion here how
well electric cars yes they use lithium
they have to mine lit strip mine lithium
and they have to mine Cobalt or nickel
or whatever material it is for the
battery that's bad for the environment
but the electric car is good for the
environment because it's not putting out
CO2 when the car is running
same way of you hydrogen be a very would
be positive in my opinion for the for
the for the environment and folks have
found blue gray and green and blue and
gray comes from natural gas which 10
years ago in this committee natural gas
was supposedly clean and it exists and
so it would be no different than lithium
bad Cobalt bad electric cars are good
blue green gray hydrogen
all good
same thing
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair I just want to make a statement
that um regarding the government's role
I personally feel that we make too many
laws quite frankly but I I believe that
um uh unless there's a obstacle or
Reason Why say the department of energy
could not go after a government grant
for for hydrogen I I say you know let
the executive branch follow their
10-year strategy and if they come across
an obstacle then they can come to us and
say we need to fix something but until
then this is almost like a you know a
solution to looking for a problem so I
think we're on the right course here at
itl is
representative Christian has a comment
thank you chair um just wanted to uh I
guess agree with my colleagues Mickey
and muns about our role of enabling
infrastructure I also know that on this
committee what's come up a few times as
concerns about much carbon neutral
technology not being dispatchable I
think that hydrogen can fill that hole
and as such we have a responsibility to
try to enable it thank you
representative Reynolds has a comment
thank you Mr chairman yeah I'd like to
thank my colleague representative
Christian for that point and uh
you know just say that when it comes to
you know all this technology and the uh
what the future brings you know we don't
have to all be experts here on it in
order to have the state of New Hampshire
make a small move recognize that this
energy technology uh is an important one
that's being taken up uh around the
country and again New Hampshire
shouldn't be the donut hole the state
that does nothing in the whole Northeast
uh to send out a signal that we're
welcoming uh this technology or
companies that might be interested in
this technology to the state so I'm
going to be voting uh against itl
further discussion
representative Kaplan you've made two
comments already do you have anything
new to add
I was just going to use your analogy of
the coupons
Mr chair and say that uh resistance to
the state offering a minimal amount of
tax credits is like saying you don't
want to go buy the newspaper so you cut
out the coupon when you're going to shop
for your groceries I mean that's it's
that Pennywise pound foolish
foreign
thank you additional comments or
questions or anything
seeing none I think uh we're at the
point where we can ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of Ito on
Senate bill
it's an amendment
we don't have an amendment on the floor
the question on the floor is itl
so I'll ask the clerk to call the role
on the question of itl on Senate bill
167.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy merner yes John leweki yes
Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
pleasure yes James Summers yes Kat McGee
no
Rebecca McWilliams no
Jackie creation no lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds No chairman Bose yes
eleven to nine
by a vote of eleven to nine
the committee report of itl is adopted
and representative
Thomas will write the committee report
and representative McGee will there be a
Minority Report yes
and who will write that I will look at
my list and I will show you in one
second
representative Tony will write the
committee it'll be Tony Kaplan
representative Kaplan will write the
committee Minority Report
today is Tuesday I would ask at all the
majority and minority reports be
submitted to me by close of business on
Thursday
all right so I'm going to close the
public hearing I mean the executive
session now on Senate bill 167.
[Music]
and let's see if we can do one or two
more before we need to take a break
all right I guess I'm being lobbied for
a break right now so let's take a 10
minute break and return return here at
10 20 for for further action on our
on our list of bills to exec today so
committee will reconvene at 10 20.
back to work thank you
okay so resuming executive session on
the Senate bills we have
five to go
so we've done seven one
we've done seven we have five to go
so with that being the case let's open
up an executive session on Senate Bill
52 relative to the regulation and
operation of electrical or electric
vehicle charging stations and the chair
recognizes representative Harrington he
said I would move to itl Senate bill 52.
chair recognizes representative Summers
I second the motion
it's moved and seconded that we itl
Senate Bill 52 chair recognizes
representative Harrington
um well first of all it is uh I have a
lot of issues with the bill because it's
not it opened up the possibility of
people other than those who use the
vehicle charging stations paying for
them
um and I just don't think that should be
the case if people want to pay for them
especially if we're looking at
out-of-state people coming up uh and
they say it's a I think the quote was a
desert or something a charging desert in
New Hampshire well they should be able
to uh have a charge such that that's
done because it's to me it's important
that the people who use the should pay
for it if you don't have an electric
vehicle you're not getting any advantage
out of having an electrical vehicle
charging stations and I don't want to
see that cost be pushed around to the
rate payers which is where we seem to
head on all these things it'll be no
different than if we said okay everybody
that has an electric vehicle doesn't buy
gas so we're going to charge them so
much money to keep gas stations running
um I just don't think it's a good idea I
think that these uh things could will
come on their own without us subsidizing
it through the rate payers
further discussion representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman I would note that
the bill does not mandate any uh any
charges anywhere just says potential
sources of funding may include but are
not limited to and then lists various
things some of which are specific to EV
owners EV registration surcharges
surcharges on electricity purchased
through public EV charging stations for
example
um
and in terms of the bill itself and the
the intent of the bill
we're going to see more electric
vehicles coming into the state
both from residents of the state who own
EVs and need to charge them and perhaps
don't have the wherewithal to do that
where they live
either that they're in apartments that
don't provide those facilities or they
just can't afford to put a charger in at
their home
but even more importantly we're going to
see people coming from out of state for
tourism
if we do not have sufficient charging
infrastructure in the state what's going
to happen is that people from
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
New York
Jersey
are not going to come here because they
feel like they won't be able to charge
up and get home our tourism industry
will feel it we will start seeing a
decline in our meals and rooms taxes as
a result as well to say nothing of the
jobs that the tourism industry supports
so I think that this bill is actually
quite essential for the economic future
of the state given how much we rely on
tourism
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair
um I don't totally disagree with my good
colleague however I have good faith in
our free market system and our private
industry and if we got to a point where
they saw that their business might be
slacking off particularly during the
summer time I believe they will do what
free market does they will invest on
their own and provide what services they
believe will keep people coming to their
to their you know position so I think
that over time people will do what is
necessary to keep their their business
going
maybe not to the extent that you feel
that that we would do it but I just
think the free market will respond when
when needed
I would add to that that last summer we
saw a huge spike in the price of natural
gas due to some
unpredictable and unexpected
geopolitical events
and also due to some policies by the
federal government
that put the brakes on oil and natural
gas exploration and exploitation
so when the price of natural gas spiked
the price of electricity followed it and
spiked as well
here we are
eight nine ten months later and the
natural price of natural gas has fallen
dramatically
why did that happen
because
the free market in natural gas
prompted producers to produce more of it
to satisfy the demand that was out there
for natural gas that's why the price
fell that's why the prices of our
electricity are going to fall in the
next
RFP process and it's proof positive that
the free market works and I agree with
representative Thomas that in this Doug
Thomas and that in this particular case
uh the free market if there's a demand
out there for electric charging stations
they'll get built no question in my mind
about that representative murder
is thank you Mr chairman
um in testimony the head of the
Automobile Dealers Association gave a
plug to my town
um we have a a Ford dealer Garage in
this in Lancaster and he solely is
invested a major amount of money into a
charging station into the town
um because there's like you guys just
stated that if there's any it's the free
market there's a demand for something
they will build it you know if there's
money in it they're going to build it we
don't have to uh subsidize these things
thank you
representative Christian has a comment
um to this point I don't disagree that
business owners will likely
um begin to incorporate this if they see
a demand however this seems to me to be
an unnecessary burden on our local
business owners for something that is
infrastructure and and seems to me like
something that that we should be doing
you know as we provide Interstate as we
provide transmission lines things like
that
um the sort of infrastructure seems like
something we should handle not something
that every corner store needs to to do
on their own thanks
thank you representative Wendy Thomas
has a comment
um thank you um this bill simply sets up
a committee there's no mandates there's
nothing that is going to take away from
anybody or anything it's a committee to
look at all aspects of Eva charging
stations and just like the hydrogen Bill
we just discussed I see this as an
enabling and a jobs bill for New
Hampshire
further comment further discussion
on the motion to itl representative
Harrington I would just use one example
I guess to show how things work if you
came to New Hampshire in the summertime
40 or 50 years ago almost no place had
air conditioning but people started to
think well we need air conditioning we
want to have air conditioning people put
in air conditioning everywhere if you
went to some place 80 years ago 90 years
ago there probably weren't that many gas
stations people started showing up with
cars they built more gas stations we
didn't require a government program to
get people to air condition their hotels
people did it because they responded to
the demands of the public they'll do the
same on this the government doesn't have
to do it
further discussion
representative muns
I I would also add to that picture of
coming to New Hampshire 40 50 60 years
ago the fact that if you tried to do
that you were most likely going on very
small two-lane roads and then the
government decided that it was ever in
everybody's best interest to build the
interstate highway system
and that it was a tremendous Boon for
New Hampshire's economy
and the private Market would not have
built that road
representative Bernardi has a comment
just to comment on interstate highway
system that was built as a defense
mechanism that was Eisenhower
Administration saying we need to have
roads where we can move the Army from
one point in the country to another
quickly
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
uh thank you I just want to add on to
the representative's comment that um
roads infrastructure that's built into
the Constitution as a responsibility of
the federal government you know
providing charging stations is not so
it's a distinction there
representative Corman has a question a
comment thank you Mr chairman uh and I
understand the point about having the
private sector provide much of the
equipment
but there's also all the front of the
meter
equipment and infrastructure that needs
to be supplied and that really is not
the responsibility of the private sector
so this is enabling legislation to see
how we're going to do that
so you don't think the utilities which
are private companies are part of the
private sector
not entirely I mean they're quite
regulated and you know I they're
regulated in fact by
the government and I think the
government needs to be looking into this
and our constitution
specifies that we want as a people to
have limited government right
representative lewiki you had a quest
comment
okay
representative Reynolds has a comment
thank you Mr chairman I think everyone
is
making some valid points but again I
think a lot of the this discussion and
the objections and concerns about this
bill again we should always be talking
about the bill and what the bill does
and the bill is not
to establish a state program of
deploying EV charging stations it's to
form a committee to look at some of the
issues
and get further into them and
probably do a service like
Define what would be the
proper limited role what might be the
proper limited role of the state
government and responsibilities of the
state government versus the private
sector or municipal government so this
bill is to establish a committee to
start to
think about this issue and help us all
understand it more I don't understand
why we keep declining to declining
efforts like on the green hydrogen Bill
too
learn more and and have a body that
would come back and inform us so that we
might make better legislation in the
future
representative partial
yes thank you I would uh Echo that uh
for the most part this is a study uh uh
committee it is not uh an uh it is not
legislation and it's to study the issue
and I'm listening to during the
testimony uh there's questions about
what does it mean by universal access
there were some suggestions that perhaps
this might be a good Avenue to look at
things like road taxes I think there's
many issues to resolve here and I don't
think that just putting our head in the
sand saying we don't think that we think
that electric cars are passing fed or
something is going to get us where we
need to be as a state we're going to
lose out so I would refer something a
motion to retain rather than something
like itl
representative Nutter
thank you the purpose of the committee
is to recommend legislation and in this
case it would be to grow government
which is against limited government
which is what we believe and we already
have over 150 commissions and committees
we have to pay mileage which is costing
the taxpayers money and we have paid
researchers let them do their job we
don't need another committee
further discussion
to amplify representative knotters point
I think this legislature
I've been in the legislature now for
nine years I think this legislature has
grown somewhat lazy over the years and
rather than put in the hard work to
research
how to develop effective legislation
there's been a tendency especially in
the last four or five years to fall back
on the
issue of creating a study committee to
do that hard work
so instead of
each of us taking the responsibility to
do the hard work
and do the research necessary to come up
with good solid legislation we want to
deflect that work onto the backs of our
colleagues who get appointed to a study
committee
study committees very often don't come
up with much useful information study
committee reports very often end up in
the circular file
and I think we need to at some point say
no
let's break the cycle of deflecting hard
questions onto the backs of study
committees
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um this study committee acknowledges
that this is a new field that has new
experts and therefore we don't have the
answers and and this bill does exactly
what we're supposed to do set up a
committee to look at a new field with
new experts
further discussion
seeing that I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of itl for
Senate Bill 52 FN
Doug Thomas yes
Janine noddard yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy Martin yes
John lewicki yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes James
Summers yes Kam McGee no Rebecca
McWilliams no
Jackie creation no
Lucius partial no Tony Kaplan no Chris
muns no
Henry Noel no Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds No
chairman Vose yes 10-10 by a vote of 10
10 the motion of itl fails
is there another motion for Senate Bill
52 FN
representative McGee I'd like to make a
motion OTP
representative McGee moves OTP is there
a second
representative Munns seconds the motion
of OTP on Center Bell 52.
representative muns
thank you Mr chair I'd like to introduce
an amendment
uh amendment number 1401
is there a second my second
representative muns moves Amendment 1401
H seconded by representative McGee
discussion on this amendment
representative Munds thank you Mr chair
um this this amendment is relatively
straightforward uh what it does is uh it
removes section four on page three of
the bill as uh amended by the Senate
which deals with
um
which which provides some direction to
the Public Utilities Commission during
the testimony we um we heard uh
testimony and we discussed the fact that
it would be premature to have the puc
taking any specific actions until the
study committee had completed its work
and there seemed to be a general
consensus that if this bill were to move
forward that it would be in
um the best interest to remove that that
requirement so that's all that this
amendment does
quick question so the amendment just
removes
starting on line 22 and going through to
line
five on page two just removes text from
the original bill
yes that's it
okay thank you further discussion
a question representative Harrington
yeah just a question so just don't get
this clear what you're saying is that
the existing bill would have the Public
Utilities Commission start an
investigation or a process before the
commission
released its report
yeah that's how I read the bill it it
basically said that the commission shall
within two years consider a number of
things and the implication is that that
would start immediately and that just
seemed premature given the fact that the
study committee hadn't even done its
work yet okay that makes sense thank you
isn't it true that during Pub the public
hearing it was explained to us that that
was old language that the reference to
two years was
a reference to two years following the
initial adoption of that statute and
that two-year period had already expired
and therefore the
language that you want to delete is
actually obsolete language it has
nothing to do with the performance of
the bill as it existed isn't that
correct
I didn't I don't recall that but that
would make sense and would just be
another reason to delete the language
further discussion on the amendment
seeing that I guess we'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the adoption of
amendment
1401 h
Doug Thomas no
Janine nodder no
Michael Harrington yes
Troy murner no
John lewicki yes
Lex barajny yes
JD Bernardi no
Tom closure yes
James Summers no
Kat McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose no
14-6 by a vote of 14-6 the amendment
1401 H is adopted
the chair now will entertain a motion of
otpa
representative muns
sorry I I moved to uh
um adopt uh adopt the bill with
amendment
otpa is there a second
representative McGee
representative McGee seconds the motion
of otpa
Is there further discussion on the bill
or on the question of otpa
representative McGee I think the only
thing I would add is we've already
discussed the fact that it's a study and
people have feelings about adding
studies and whether we should be doing
the work versus a study
um I think everyone on the committee
doesn't have to do all of the work and I
think it makes sense on something that
we have so many questions about and so
many differing opinions that we actually
do allow a study to go forward so we can
have some of those answers that's that's
all I'd add
any further discussion
okay seeing none I'll ask clerk to call
the role on the question of otpa on
Senate bill 52.
Doug Thomas no
Janine nodder no
Michael Harrington no
Troy Marner no
John lewicki no
Lex barajny no
JD Bernardi no Tom closure no James
Summers no Kat McGee
yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Christmas yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes jeremose no 10 10.
by a vote of 10 they ought to pass as
amended motion fails
the next motion that the chair would
entertain his emotion to retain
I personally have no appetite for that
but if the committee does have an
appetite for retain I would entertain
such emotion
I'd like to make a motion to retain
representative McGee moves to retain
Senate Bill 52
is there a second
representative
representative partial seconds the
motion to retain
I'll start the discussion by pointing
out that we've already retained 13 bills
in this committee this year
and that presents a fairly substantial
workload for us either in the month of
June if I can convince the speaker to
let us begin to begin early
or in starting in the month of September
Mr chair so I would just urge you all to
keep that in mind as you try to decide
whether this bill is worth retaining Mr
Senator McGee yeah I just wanted to say
I I I'll withdraw my motion to retain
because I think it's fairly unusual to
retain a study committee bill either
we're going to say there will be a study
committee or they won't so will this go
to the floor without recommendation then
yes it will okay
okay so representative McGee withdraws
her motion to retain the bill therefore
the bill will go to the floor without
recommendation
the motion on the floor will be ought to
pass as amended by
Amendment 1401 h
that will be the first motion
so
we need a committee report
from representative Corman
Gorman will write the motion for
ought to pass
and representative Harrington will write
the
motion for itl
okay once again I'll remind members to
um
submit your committee reports to me by
close of business on Thursday
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on I mean the executive session
on Senate bill 52.
now we can open a executive session on
Senate bill 54.
so representative McGee and I have been
discussing what to do about Senate bill
54.
and we would like to propose jointly
that we
form a subcommittee
to study the issues that were raised in
the public hearing that we had yesterday
and make a recommendation to the full
committee
we would recess the
exec committee on this bill today
and notice it on a future date
probably the first of May
if we did form such a subcommittee
the subcommittee would likely meet next
Monday April 24th
so I would like to hear discussion from
the members about whether you think a
subcommittee is desirable or if you want
to proceed
with making a passing judgment on this
bill today
representative McGee
yes Mr chair
um
do you want me to make the motion for
the subcommittee
no I won't speak to I don't think we
need a motion to do that I think what we
need is a discussion of whether it's
worthwhile yes
um I think what happened in the hearing
is that we had
um
we had testimony from varying
stakeholders in and around our committee
that were in opposition to each other
where decisions need to be made and
greater discussion I think and
understanding needs to be obtained by
this committee before we can say that
we're comfortable putting through a bill
that's kind of a sea change in terms of
policy so some of those open questions
require additional Examination for us to
be sure that what we're passing is going
to actually have the effects that we uh
you know kind of we agree that we would
like to see prices come down we're not
convinced that that will be the effect
of the bill before us and so I think we
just want to do a little more due
diligence before we let the bill pass
through the committee
further discussion on the question of
whether we should form a subcommittee to
look further into this bill
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman I'm going off of
what I said yesterday that I'm in favor
of helping the ratepayer any way we can
and there was the couple lines where I
said it would have to be stricken before
I'd ever go for it and that was line 18
and 19. so if there was any work to be
done to where the rate payers did were
not responsible for the difference
between the agreement payments and
proceeds through uniform annual factors
and rates then I think could be
worthwhile
representative Kaplan
yeah I think it's very worthwhile I
think we're very close to an agreement
that would satisfy the people on this
committee who have doubts and lack trust
in in this bill but I think we're close
and I I think given our willingness to
work in a bipartisan fashion as we've
seen today that we ought to set
something up also we heard yesterday in
committee that there's a bit of a state
of emergency in the energy market so we
should be working in a timely fashion to
get something passed
so I think we should put our money where
our mouths are speaking from my side of
the aisle I think it's time that we
maybe uh we've been talking about
Renewables being the most cost effective
choice for a long time and I think we
need to trust that this is a moment now
that we might be able to start to see
that and I think from the other side of
the aisle you've been talking about
cost Effectiveness and pricing criteria
being the the sole guideline or the main
priority when it comes to policy making
so again uh you need to put your your
money where your mouths are so I think
in a bipartisan fashion we could start
to work uh work our way through this
bill and um
write the apple cart of the energy
Market which is already being disrupted
as we speak and so um this is this bill
is an effort to to try to seize the
moment it is a sea change it is a big
Bill but it's an important move for the
state and it's uh we owe it to our we
owe it to the Senate who worked in a
bipartisan fashion to craft this we owe
it to our constituents to try to do
something about electricity rates and
for many of us it's a priority issue so
yes I'm in favor of it
additional discussion representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman yes so yeah
I when I think about this bill I think
that it's uh its purpose is also for
Price stabilization uh because it would
provide a backstop on pricing
as a about to be
customer of community power I am
concerned about the effect on community
power and I would like to see us do what
we can to make this bill not hurt
Community power representative McGee
called me last night and and mentioned
the subcommittee idea to me and asked if
I would be willing to serve on it and if
I am asked to I I am willing
thank you representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you um I just want
to um so we're recessing this as opposed
to retaining it is that because we think
that we're close to a resolution and we
want to get it onto the floor before the
end of this session that is correct okay
thank you if we retain the bill it
doesn't come to the floor till next fall
our next January basically
but if we just recess this exact session
then we can resume the exact session at
a time and date to be noticed in the
calendar and move the bill forward this
session this spring
so that would be the goal of doing a
subcommittee representative McGee yes
and before we go forward with voting on
whether to form one I just wanted to put
out there to the committee that one of
the things that I suggested uh to
Chairman Vose was that we by way a
process try to put out a question to all
of you to try and let us know
submit to to us what your concerns are
with the bill so that we know that we're
um addressing all of them in our
attempts to review it I mean we're going
to review it anyway but I think there
are certain things that stick out
um to different of our members and so we
would like to have everyone's concerns
um addressed in that subcommittee and it
would also expediate the process if we
had a list of questions we were trying
to solve for so if you have ideas about
like the suggestion that representative
Summers made about his position on lines
18 and 19. we we would like to collect
that information just to make the work
more Speedy thanks
so I'm getting a sense that the
committee is interested in pursuing this
option but to be absolutely sure could I
see a show of hands who from individuals
representative Arrington has a question
first
I just want to know if let's just say we
have this and we have that one day
meeting next week and and it still
doesn't come to Felician so is this
still the option then to retain the bill
sure as long as the executive session is
still open which it would be then retain
would still be because one thing I think
we need to hear more from is where the
puc is where they're doing with this and
where they're going and how they think
it's going to work and so forth because
obviously they've been involved in this
stuff before and it's going to have an
impact on you know on them directly so
that way I don't think we heard from the
chair of the puc on this yet have we
okay sure the chair of the puc did
anyone from the puc speak on this on the
public hearing I wasn't here for the
first no I guess I was here for it they
weren't no only the department of energy
testified on the bill not the BSC
all right so to be sure in my mind that
my sense of a consensus is correct I
would like to see a show of hands of
people who would like to form a
subcommittee and recess the exact
session on Senate bill 54.
please raise your hand
so it looks like we have a consensus so
that is the direction in which we will
move
so representative McGee and I move the
formation of a subcommittee for Senate
bill 64. that's 54 rather
and
I would like to
appoint the following people to the
committee
representative Corman representative
Bernardi representative McGee
representative Harrington and
representative Vose
without objection
those folks will be the subcommittee for
Senate bill 54.
excuse me what day is this going to be
Monday April 24th will be the
meeting of the subcommittee
I'm in Portsmouth that afternoon for an
offshore wind commission hearing what
time
4 30 but I'm not driving out here and
driving all the way back over there so
you have to find somebody else on that
one
okay so well scratch representative
Harrington
yes nine o'clock in the morning
so representative Thomas
I'll be going to the same ultra wind
meaning but at 4 30 yeah okay
okay
so I'd make sure 18 and 19 aren't in
there
all right so
Bose McGee Bernardi Corman and Summers
okay representative Kaplan just
wondering I mean this is a split
committee 1010 why why wouldn't the
subcommittee also be equally split
between the the two parties side you
know just just a question to process
it's impossible to come up with an even
split when you need an odd number of
people
mathematically can't work
so remember what a subcommittee does is
it asks questions compiles information
and then makes a decision about a
recommendation or a series of
recommendations to make to the full
committee
so the subcommittee will come back to us
and say
we recommend
that you amend Senate Bill 54 in these
three ways
and the committee itself the full
committee can say yes or no to that
recommendation
or it could even modify the
recommendation and say okay we'll take
two of those
will reject one and we'll add one of our
own you know that's that's the kind of
thing that can happen
so that's what the subcommittee process
is supposed to that's how it's supposed
to work
and you have to have a an odd number of
people on a subcommittee so that there
won't be tie votes if you end up voting
on something
so
that's the uh that's the strategy we'll
we will take here
so given that I will now recess the
public the executive session on Senate
Bill 54 to a time and date to be noticed
in the calendar
and I will schedule a subcommittee
meeting
I will chair the subcommittee and I'll
schedule a meeting for Monday April 24th
at 9 00 A.M
here yes in this room
and
to be clear
even though there are five members of
the subcommittee every member of this
committee is
welcome and eligible to attend the
meeting
and to sit at this table and ask
questions if you have them
so even though the five members of the
subcommittee will actually form
formulate the recommendations that we
will prevent present to the full
committee the full committee is welcome
to attend if you so desire
it is a public meeting so
the public is invited to the meeting as
well
to listen to the questions that get
asked
and the deliberations that the committee
ends up making I anticipate that it'll
be a pretty full day
the morning will probably be spent
asking questions and then the afternoon
will probably be spent
deliberating well what do we do with the
information we gained
what amendments are we going to
recommend
Etc
any other questions about how the
subcommittee process will work
okay I guess we're done with that then
so we're recessed on Senate bill 54. we
can now move on to Senate bill 68.
and the chair recognizes representative
Bernardi for a motion
Mr chairman I move itl
chair recognizes representative merner
I second the motion Mr chairman moved
and seconded that we itl Senate Bill
and uh chair recognizes representative
Bernardi to
a discussions motion
yes uh Mr chairman as as we've discussed
in the hearing
um what what we're doing here is
continuing this continues to expand the
concept of uh of
making net metering available to a
larger and larger group of subgroup of
of uh
potential customers and uh we we did
that initially for
municipalities where the net metering
benefit went back to the taxpayers of
those municipalities in in these
subsequent bills
um that is not the circumstance that
obtains so uh it it is that sort of
unrestricted growth is not well uh we
should be doing
thank you further discussion I'll remind
the members that we did
this bill mirrors
hb139 which came out of committee
without recommendation and then was
passed on the house floor and so the
position of itl of
the Republican caucus is consistent with
our position on hb-139
further discussion
representative McGee I guess I'll just
add this by way of explanation
um yeah I think
um
originally we had heard since there were
two vehicles that were very similar one
on each side of the wall that perhaps
the one that was coming to us SB 68
would be the one that would be preferred
for passage but I think it's actually
um
you know at this point it's it's the
other way I I think HB 39 did make it
through the house and the Senate is is
looking at passing it on their side so
um I don't think we you know have any
further jurisdiction over that
particular bill but in this one I think
it's um
it's not necessary
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of itl on
Senate bill 68.
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine knotter yes
Michael Harrington yes
Troy Marner yes
John lewicki yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes James
Summers yes Kat McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes
Cameron Bose yes
19-1
buy a vote of 19-1 the adoption the
motion of itl is adopted on Senate bill
68. without objection we'll put this on
the
uh consent calendar
seeing and hearing no consent this will
go on the consent calendar and
representative Bernardi will write the
committee report
and with that we'll close the executive
session on Senate bill 68.
it is now 1105 we have two bills to go
so I'll open the executive session on
Senate bill 69.
relative to allowing certain non-profits
to participate as customer generator
group hosts under net energy metering
and I'll recognize representative
Harrington for a motion
inappropriate to legislate
representative is recognized I second
ICL on SB 69. it's moved and seconded
that we itl Senate bill 69.
and the chair recognizes representative
Harrington
this is just another expansion of the
net metering process that we started we
originally it was supposed to be up to
one megawatt and then we decided okay
well we'll allow municipalities to go up
is from one to five with the idea that
if they saved money on the electric bill
the tax payers would save money now
we're talking about doing it to multiple
non-profit groups and as people had
mentioned before they're one of the
largest employees in the state so this
could really expand we could be talking
about hundreds of megawatts of power
which is net metered which means again
it has no obligation to deliver power at
any time when they have the power it has
to be bought at the net meter in price
when they don't Supply the power maybe
when it's really needed something
certainly like and we all talk about the
winter time here and how desperate we
are for electricity in the winter you're
not going to get much out of solar uh
when it's a real cold morning in January
or if it's snowing out for example
so we just keep pushing it a little bit
more we open the door now we're going to
be and then we have another bill that
says basically anybody can do it I think
we should leave the the line where it's
been drawn whereas municipalities only
because that way there is a direct
saving to to taxpayers on that and let's
face it everybody that lives somewhere
pays property taxes one way or the other
so I just don't see this and it's just
going to exacerbate the problem we could
end up like I say hundreds of megawatts
of solar that has no obligation to serve
at any particular time and that means
we're going to have to have more Reserve
power to back that up and the iso always
going to pay those people to have
Reserve power to be there just in case
not running but just in case and of
course that's going to be passed on 100
to the rate payers
thank you for the discussion
representative Kaplan
I'm yeah I think I'm just going to use
an analogy to try to argue in favor of
this bill I mean we're trying to build a
bridge to the Future and we're halfway
across the bridge and we're calling a
pause on construction of that bridge
yes solar energy is intermittent and it
has problems but uh they're not
they're not unsolvable problems and
we need to do as much as we can to
diversify our energy our generating
sources in order to lower prices uh
because of our dependence on natural gas
and so this is one way of doing it it's
not perfect but it's the way we've
started and uh as you said or somebody
mentioned non-profits or a huge source
of uh economic activity in our state and
we should be doing what we can to help
them
representative Bernardi
so to follow up on uh representative
kaplan's statement what we want to do is
build a bridge to the Future that will
be there some days
but not other days
representative Corman has a question or
a comment thank you Mr chairman uh yeah
a couple of things I would I would say
um
you know I was thinking last night about
representative Harrington's comments
representative berezny actually prompted
me to think of him thank you
representative and one thing I think
about is the amount of solar compared
with the base load that we already have
it just doesn't seem like that much
certainly not in the near term
um and then I'll just repeat something I
said yesterday when we were discussing
this bill in the work session which is
I'm involved with a non-profit and of
course as representative munz pointed
out the nonprofit sector is a huge
employer in the state but I am directly
involved with the non-profit as a board
member and actually I was the grant
writer I know how hard it is for
non-profits to survive financially and I
feel like this is something that we can
do to help non-profits and the question
was also raised well uh this is not
really helping the the rate payers and
the taxpayers but when you look at who
the non-profits are helping throughout
the state it's a lot of people not just
the people that work for the non-profits
or with the nonprofits it's a lot of
people and I feel like the benefit of
this actually can spread out across a
huge swath of the state
additional discussion representative
Reynolds has a question or comment
thank you Mr chairman and uh yes thank
you representative Corman for pointing
that out this bill course it represents
an expansion of the eligibility
for all of our state's nonprofits to
take advantage of low-cost solar which
would help
a lot of people across the state and I
just need to respond to
um
representative Harrington's you know
repeated characterization of of solar
that it's not reliable it doesn't have
an obligation to serve he's not wrong
about that but it's it's really
irrelevant to the question
um the characteristics of solar are what
they are
and we've been
shown by the repeated testimony New
England power generators Association
utilities that solar in the aggregate
already makes a substantial reduction in
demand across the region and that
reduction in demand has benefits for
ratepayers so we ought to continue to do
things that allow private investors to
build more solar
no solar's not dispatchable doesn't have
an obligation to serve but the natural
gas plants are dispatchable and to the
extent that um
you know they can be turned on when
needed so since natural gas is a limited
resource pipeline capacity into New
Hampshire New England is limited why
shouldn't we save the natural gas for
when we really need it and have people
build solar so that when it is
generating and contributes to the grid
it can be taken advantage of so it's
it's
a sort of a false choice that that
representative Harrington is is uh
is presenting us with we ought to do
this and we ought to do it for the
industrial as well thank you so since
you called out representative Harrington
I'll call on him
thank you just just to clarify the
difference between these when you talk
about natural gas plants I know of none
that have that are almost none that are
under five megawatts so they were all
dispatchable plants controlled by ISO
New England so the way it works is
they'll bid in on it on a particular
hour that I'm going to deliver 100
megawatts of power and if that clears
then they deliver the power now if that
particular day there's a lot of solar
being produced and ISO New England says
we don't need your 100 megawatts well
they're going to say too bad you're
going to pay me for them anyways that's
the way it works just because there's
extra sold that's not dispatchable now
if it's a utility grade solar that's 50
megawatts or something they'll have an
obligation to sell their electricity and
deliver it but if someone is Bid in and
cleared the market and it happens to be
an exceptionally sunny day or a day that
it was supposed to rain and it didn't
and there's a lot more net metered solar
around there it doesn't cut back on the
you can't tell the natural gas plant
sorry we're not gonna you can't run
today because they've already bought
their gas they're ready to go and
they've cleared the market and they're
going to get paid that's just the way it
works and if you tell them not to run
then they're going to get paid anyways
you can't you can't it's two totally
different things because one has a
commitment that they make and they clear
the market the other one runs whenever
they whenever they can whenever they
want them
representative lewicki as a comment um
thank you Mr chairman you know we hear
about the reliability must run and other
such plants and the thing is that the
rate payers are paying for essentially
that capacity
um in excess of whatever the solar may
do and uh until we have storage solar is
the
sometimes here sometimes not and we
heard about the Christmas Eve issue and
the other one where we were running
really low and we can't say hey solar
come on you know Christmas Eve we need
some juice right now it's four o'clock
in the afternoon it just doesn't work
that way it can't be done
representative Bernardi has a comment
yes I just just to uh round out what uh
representatives lewicking and Harrington
are talking about
um because solar is not reliable
meaning dispatchable
uh it does not reduce our overall demand
of the amount of power resources we need
there is never any solar during the
winter Peak none absolutely zero because
in the winter Peak it is dark
therefore we have to have another set of
reliable power producers
100 percent throughout the the whole
year in order to in order to satisfy
that Peak so basically what we're doing
is saying we need to build out two
sources of Power by this bill one solar
and one to cover the peak that doesn't
make any sense we should not be
subsidizing that kind of activity
uh just to keep in mind how much space
that solar Farms take up so if we wanted
to replace all conventional power plants
we would need
land larger than the state of California
representative cretian
thank you um I just wanted to bring us
back to the actual bill so this is only
allowing non-profits in the state to
participate as net metered host we are
not talking about replacing all natural
gas with solar we are not talking about
anything the size of California this is
just expanding it to a very small
additional number of folks it will save
on the peak we've heard testimony to
that effect we've seen studies to that
effect I don't think we should ignore
that
um
I think we're just getting getting far
off of what the bill will do and into
the sort of more controversial aspects
of you know 100 renewable which is not
what this is talking about
representative murder yes I I agree with
her on the the but there's a large large
amount of non-profits I can't even tell
you how many just in the North Country
Alone
um and to the point just to stay on
point of the money
these going on you'd be surprised how
many non-profits there are for that
would jump on this boat the other thing
we we don't understand when we talk
about cost shifting or whatever we are
paying millions of dollars to have these
plants on standby right now Bo runs
twice a year we could I could go on and
on with all the plants that were on
standby right now and what's going to
have you know we still have to pay them
because this is not reliable base load
power and it will expand significantly
with Dawn profits I'm sorry there is an
awful lot out there and I'll just leave
it at that
to follow on to representative merner's
point
because there are a huge number of
non-profits and I agree that many of
them struggle to survive
but this bill would open the door to
allowing
consortiums or cooperatives of
non-profits to join into the to this
program of
additional net readering because they're
non-profits and that is a huge expansion
potential expansion of the net metering
work Marketplace when
the public utilities Public Utilities
Commission is still trying to figure out
what the net metering tariff should be
going forward
and the doe opposes this bill because we
they think we should wait do we know
what that tariff is before we expand net
metering any further
so representative munz has a comment
thank you Mr chair and I'm um I'm
encouraged that everyone on the
committee seems to acknowledge that the
non-profit segment of our economy is is
large and and very um
important to the overall well-being of
the
of the state and I I wanted to thank
representative Corman for highlighting
the fact that these non-profits serve a
very large segment of the population the
only thing that I would add to his
comment is that New Hampshire is unique
among states and that we Outsource a lot
of what our normal governmental
responsibilities to non-profits
our social service system has been
essentially outsourced to non-profits
and um I think we have an obligation
to assist those non-profits as much as
we can to enable them to continue to be
able to function and fulfill the mission
that we the state have asked them to
fulfill
so anything we can do to reduce their
operating costs
um will will be beneficial to them and
quite frankly if they want to get
together in consortiums that's that's
the free market at work and I would
encourage them to do that
further discussion
representative McGee
thank you
um so it clearly you know our differing
perspectives on whether we should be
enabling this portion of the clean
energy or local energy Market uh is
going to continue to be disparate but
what I would say is that uh on the on
the issue of you know base load versus
intermittent energy sources
as was stated before those are the
characteristics and what ends up
happening is if you have larger
non-profits like hospitals and that sort
of thing they may end up partnering in
such a way
um as they will invest in storage in
order to accommodate being able to
dispatch energy when needed so I think
we're not here to prescribe how the
market will interpret the laws and the
policies that we put in place we're here
to figure out which policies work for
New Hampshire and I think these bills
were this bill and the next bill were
both put in for specific constituencies
who see themselves wanting to be enabled
in that regard and want to lower their
prices and I think you know it from my
perspective there isn't a downside to
that it doesn't matter what the Tariff
is the Tariff will be what the Tariff
will be the policy is whether or not
these guys are allowed to lower their
own costs if they so see fit and right
now the only impediment they have to
that is us
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chairman
this is a classic example of trying to
pass a policy before we know how this
policy is going to affect everybody and
in reference to the puc is still doing
work on tariffs we have no idea what
this policy is going to do it may or may
not be what we want or it may
increase people's costs this policy I
think is premature we need to wait till
POC acts just like a doe has recommended
representative Bernardi
just a comment on representative McGee's
statement a little closer statement we
there is no impediment for any
non-profit or any other organization to
begin or build out solar or wind now
what we're talking about is should we be
giving them a subsidy
representative Harrington
I just make a quick comment uh we use
the word non-profit fairly Loosely and
it just doesn't mean the United Fund or
the YMCA there's an awful lot of
non-profits in New Hampshire I believe
the gun club I belong to is a non-profit
so when you start taking across the
board there's all sorts of non-profits
and they're not all out there spending
their days making the place a better
place for everybody to live so just be
aware of that
looks like we're probably not going to
change each other's minds on this but
I'll give representative Kaplan an
opportunity to do that
thank you Mr chair I don't think this is
going to change anybody's mind but I
just can't let the uh Let It Go without
comment on on the question of terrorists
I think that's a red herring I mean this
bill is not setting the tariffs the
tariffs will be set by the puc and it's
docket and that I assume will be
retroactive to any bill that we might
pass here so why you know why are we
holding up action on something
based on
we don't know the final cost I mean that
that's that's not what this bill does
it's just it's just allows net metering
to be expanded to non-profits and I I
think of you know non-profits as Prime
candidates for for a program like this
uh seeing that they are non-profits so
I would comment that
with all due respect to my good friend
from Hollis
a policy like this actually sets up
barriers to the operation of the free
market and I don't think that that's
what we should be doing as a policy
committee is to
creating impediments to the operation of
a market which has proved to be very
effective
for 200 over 200 years in this country
all right is any further comment on this
motion to itl House Bill 69 seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the role on
the question of itl for sb69
Doug Thomas
yes
yes Michael Harrington yes Troy Marner
yes John lewcki yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes James
Summers yes Kat McGee no Rebecca
McWilliams no
Jackie creation no
Lucia's partial nope Tony Kaplan nope
Chris muns no Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas nope
Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds no
chair of house yes
10 10. my Abode of 10 to 10 the motion
by TL fails
is there any appetite for
OTP or retain
I'd like to make a motion OTP
representative McGee moves OTP is there
a second representative Corman moves
second or second to the motion of OTP is
there any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of OTP
as soon as he has filled out the
requisite paperwork and forms
necessary to the purpose
of calling the role
on the question
of OTP
on Senate bill
69.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine nodder no
Michael Harrington no
Troy Marner no
John lewicki no Lex barajny no JD
Bernardi no Tom blocker no James Summers
no Kat McGee
yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Gorman
yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose No 10
10.
a vote of 10 to 10 the motion of ought
to pass on Senate Bill 69 fails
is there any appetite on the committee
to retain this bill no
one would hope not
since we have a heavy load already
so this bill will go to the floor of the
house without recommendation
who will write the
calendar report for the motion of ought
to pass
representative muns has offered
representative muns will write the
ought to pass motion
and representative Harrington will write
the itl motion
chair what was the deadline on that
again
Thursday at 5
pm
all right one last bill to go well let
me close the uh executive session on 69
first now we'll open a executive session
on 79 Senate Bill 79
which is a very similar Bill to the one
we just did instead of
non-profits it opens the door to
um
an expansion of net metering via
industrial entities
which are somewhat defined in the bill
although it is somewhat vague so
um
on this bill I'm going to call on
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair I motion SB 79 itl
chair recognizes representative closure
I second the itl on SB 79 moved in
seconded that we itl Senate bill 79.
discussion representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair in addition to what
was discussed from the previous bill
this is a case of
for-profit organizations that would be
profiting from this bill at the expense
of our rate payers I don't believe
that's a particularly fair and for that
reason uh we should I tell this bill
further discussion
representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman and this applies to both bills
reductio Adam certum is a valid logical
proof taking things to the extreme and
saying well what happens if everybody
goes uh solar or whatever whatever and
we still have to maintain base load it
doesn't make any difference whether we
are talking about it at just one level
or you know some small one but that
reduction is a valid proof and if it is
true for uh at the extreme it's also
true for a limited case
thank you good point
additional discussion on the motion of
Ito representative closure
as we've seen the RSA
362. it's been enacted for uh what's the
title it limited limited electrical
energy producers Act
as we see the capital is trying to get
its nose Under the Tent everywhere these
two bills example of it
thank you additional discussion
representative McGee
um
my point would be that this is another
effort to try and spur competition and
fuel diversity and local sustainable
energy so that we are not as beholden to
the kinds of price spikes that we had
um last year so there's we have a
difference of opinion of how to view
solving for that problem but I I think
you know on on my in my caucus we're
firmly of the opinion that if folks want
to contribute to the market that we
should enable it so that they have a
cost structure that allows them to do so
because it will be helpful to the state
of New Hampshire and in the case of SB
79 we heard from two of our largest
long-term businesses and they were
it was excellent testimony as was what
was submitted to us in support of the
fact that they are desperate for us to
allow them to participate in creating
that competitive market so there is
another way to look at this which is not
that we're preventing people from
from being harmed by market competition
but that we are enabling Market
competition for the downward pressure
that it puts on
the cost of energy and that's that's how
I view it
thank you further discussion
representative munz
thank you Mr chair
um we we like to talk about New
Hampshire being a business friendly
state
um and
um but but but one of the things when
you when businesses are surveyed
throughout the state and asked what are
the things that determine whether they
will expand here or remain here
two of the most important items are
Workforce and energy costs
um one of the least important is taxes
and yet we are very willing to
give businesses tax reductions that they
don't want
but when it comes to giving them the the
opportunity to address one of the
biggest costs that they face by enabling
them to do net metering if they want to
and receive the benefits of net metering
somehow we're unwilling to do that and
that just doesn't make sense to me
representative Bernardi
again I must say that nothing in our
current law prevents any business from
building any solar system or wind system
that they have the land and the proper
zoning to address nothing at all if they
want to do that to reduce their costs
they are more than welcome to do it
to follow up on representative
Bernardi's comment it would seem since
companies are free to do this if they're
not doing it because they're they want a
subsidy that kind of proves the case
that net metering is indeed a subsidy
otherwise people would just go ahead and
build solder and not worry about getting
net metering subsidies
isn't that the case representative
Bernardi
I concur with that assessment 100
representative Corman
oh thank you Mr chair I just want to
point out that we did have testimony uh
from John Morrison of hitchner
manufacturing and he gave us a letter
that was supported by hitchner and eight
other companies one of which was
Stonyfield which also gave us their own
letter so Stonyfield supports this
Stonyfield organic and then also we had
the business and industry Association in
favor of this bill the entire Bia
so the question occurs then if it's good
business to expand solar
but not good business to expand solar
unless you get a subsidy
is that really good business
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman so I can relate to
this just recently in fact I was over a
week and a half ago I went on the
Tesla's website and I was looking
actually looking at the really cool
solar panels they had and this battery
storage they have available put in your
house
and so I was looking at it and then they
have a price structure on their website
tells you how long you'd make your money
back and for me it was about 10 years
I'd be able to be positive of my
electrical rate but in that whole time
of me buying it and looking at it to
purchase it from my house thinking I'd
get my money back in 10 years not once
did I expect the government to pay me
for it
further comment further discussion
representative partial
uh I would suggest the government made
the uh legislation available so you
could get a 10-year
return on your investment the same way
the government should be making it
available for these companies to get a
reasonable return on their investment
for their solar
and I would also add that when we're
already Subs I'm hearing the word
subsidy a lot we're subsidizing the oil
industry to the tune of 5.9 trillion
every year and every dollar we send out
a state to subsidize oil
means that we can't subsidize a
home-grown uh resource such as
solar when our businesses are asking for
it and when our businesses are asking
for it
it seems the reasonable thing to do to
support homegrown New Hampshire
businesses the return it will be there
the employees will they'll have more
employees more people spending dollars
in the state it's just common sense I I
don't see why there's even any debate on
this
in 2022 according to the Energy
Information assist
Administration which was part of the U.S
department of energy 85 percent of
subsidies went to wind and solar
representative Bernardi has a comment
thank you Mr chairman yes I am not aware
of any subsidies that go to the oil and
gas industry what what we have is an
Administration that is essentially
hostile to the development of oil and
gas at this point in time not
subsidizing it
there are oil and gas depreciation
allowances which are
covered by the Energy
Information Administration but those are
depreciation basically of assets similar
to what any other business does
representative Doug Thomas thank you
just to add to that what I would say is
that all those the all of what we just
said about subsidies that's at the
federal level the state does not give
any subsidies to to the oil industry and
that's a totally different animal we
have the control over the Federal
representative Kaplan
I was uh just suggested thank you Mr
chair I I would just suggest that the
price structure that we set up for net
metering can't be counted as a subsidy
it's just the price structure that the
market is set up and it's been enabled
by the state and if if if that has
determined to be faulty then we should
reset the price structure but uh that
you you can't call it a subsidy if the
state has set up a price
representative Harrington I agree with
what your opening statement that we're
not going to change anybody's mind here
so can we just really we just wasting
our time here uh can we move the
question
okay I think uh there's a sentiment that
we moved the question so
uh I would like to do that
so I'd ask the clerk to call the role in
the question of itl on Senate bill 79.
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine otter yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy murder yes John lewicki yes Lex
brajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet
yes James Summers yes Kat McGee no
Rebecca McWilliams no Jackie creation
no
lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan nope Chris muns no Henry
Noel no
Wendy Thomas no Thomas Carmen no Ed
Reynolds No chairman Vose yes
10 10. by a vote of 10 10 the motion of
itl fails is there any appetite for a
motion of OTP or retain
well I'd like to make a motion of OTP
get it on the record representative
McGee moves OTP is there a second
representative McWilliams seconds the
motion of OTP
is there any discussion
representative McGee
yes I'll just go back to the comments I
had when we made the motion to stop
um the point that I would make is that
when we characterize things as subsidies
saying any money that goes out is you
know is is a subsidy
um I would like to clarify that what we
heard
um Stonyfield uh Ann hitchner saying is
that they've already invested uh in some
infrastructure locally in order to try
and lower their bills but what they
recognize is that the true value of the
energy that they're creating is not
something that they're able to
recompense with just their individual
investment so if the actual value were
being allowed to be submitted to people
who invest in that infrastructure in the
state then they would be making their
money back quicker and they would they
would be willing to invest more and so
and that benefit would occur to
everybody in the distribution area in
which they reside unless they're only as
this bill States oh only able to to net
meter up to their own needs in the prior
12 months so the bill has guard rails
but I would reiterate that they came to
us and told us what the problem is and
for us to use
vague ideas like it's a subsidy it's a
this is that just to put a negative
connotation on it we should be listening
to the people that are
um coming in here to give us information
about what it's like on the ground
representative lewicki has a comment uh
one thing that I believe is the case is
that these companies are paying Peak
billing basically they pay for the
maximum amount of electricity so they
have the choice of either stopping
production when the sun's not shining or
paying for electricity off the grid at
the peak rate and so they're basically
in the same situation where they're
paying double even if they aren't using
the electricity
I think we're pretty well talked out on
this question so
I would ask the clerk now to call the
role on the question about to pass on
Senate bill 79.
Doug Thomas no
Janine nodder no Michael Harrington no
Troy Marner no
uh John lewicki no Lex barajny
JD Bernardi no Tom plushie
James Summers
Kat McGee
Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie creation
lucious partial yes Tony Kaplan
Chris muns
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes General bows
no
and ten by a vote of 10 10 the motion
about TP fails is there any appetite on
the committee for a motion to retain
no
thank goodness
with that we'll say that the
recommendation on the floor will be
without recommendation
and representative uh Doug Thomas will
write the
case for the motion of itl who will
write the case for the motion of
OTP
representative Reynolds will write the
ought to pass case
and I'll remind everyone that you're
reports are due by 5 PM on Thursday this
coming Thursday
so that concludes the exact session on
Senate Bill 79
which thankfully concludes our work for
the day
so we're out of here by noon time and we
get to enjoy the afternoon and the
weather seems to be improving out there
so maybe we'll get a chance to enjoy
some outdoor activity this afternoon so
I want to thank everybody for your hard
work getting us to this point
and remind everybody that on Monday
there will be Monday April 24th there
will be a subcommittee meeting of the
Senate Bill 54 subcommittee
and the five members of the subcommittee
will be asking questions and looking for
answers and anybody is welcome to attend
that meeting it'll be right here in this
room starting at 9 00 a.m on the 24th
and anybody is welcome to be here and
participate
commissioner to be there yes we will ask
the POC to be there as well so although
they won't be able to comment on an open
docket but yeah
representative Doug Thomas has a
announcement
did did his microphone appear to be not
working
did everybody hear me at the title
did everybody hear his announcement
okay
his mic doesn't seem to be working right
testing testing
light was on nobody was home though
all right all right there
thank you